well let's go back to that sad news we
had from uh the sporting world there of
the death of the australian uh cricket
legend shane warren at just 52 years old
of a heart attack
in thailand we're going to go straight
to our sports correspondent
parmenter
and tom
such a shock for the sporting world
isn't this just 52 years old
yeah a quite stunning announcement
really about one of the most popular
legendary figures
in the game of crickets 52 years old and
shane warren
is
by all accounts the best spinner ever to
have played the game or certainly one of
the very best because
this was someone who announced his
arrival onto the international scene
with australia in 1993 with one of the
most
extraordinary deliveries from a spin
bowler you will ever see
a ball that pitched and moved so far
that the england batsman mike gatting
just simply stared
at what had happened and that was shane
warren arriving
in test cricket in an ash's test at old
trafford in manchester in 1993 and he
went on to have one of the most
extraordinary careers
both on and off the cricket field and
when he turned up in test cricket he
looked very much like he'd just come off
a surf beach in australia the bleach
blonde hair the dazzling white teeth
but this was someone whose skill as a
spin bowler was unparalleled and someone
who
up until
just these last few weeks has been a key
part of the game a very visible face as
a commentator pundit
commentating
on
great cricket moments but many of them
not surpassing his own achievements
within cricket and it is the second huge
loss for australian cricket in the space
of this week because rodney marsh
also uh died this week and shane warns
last tweet was actually about
the fellow australian cricketing legend
and it is
a moment that has stunned cricket some
just dumbfounded reactions from people
that this 52 year old is now no longer
with us and someone who has contributed
so much to the game of cricket he had
quite a colorful life away from cricket
as well um has three
children and
just a stunning announcement as i say
that has really rocked the world of
cricket and i think more broadly than
that as well shane warne is someone that
even if you don't follow cricket you're
probably aware of um he has been in
thailand most recently that is where he
sadly died he and he had been posting on
social media about a new fitness push
that he was having to try and get back
to the physique that he had a couple of
years ago
um but as you say his management
confirming that in a short statement
that they have put out today one of the
greatest cricketers of all time shane
warren uh dying the
message that he put out earlier this
week about rod marsh the other
australian legend to have died this week
was that
rod cared deeply about cricket and gave
so much especially to australian england
players sending lots of love
to his family